kann ein computer nur mithilfe von
algorithmen kunst erschaffen algorithmen
sind das herzstück eines jeden computer
programms im grunde genommen sind es nur
aneinander gereihte befehle die etwas
berechnen
aber diese codes zahlen bestimmen
inzwischen große teile unseres lebens
sogar viel mehr als man sich im alltag
bewusst ist sie navigieren uns durch die
stadt handeln eigenständig mit aktien
bestimmt unsere facebook timeline und
schlagen uns sogar mögliche partner beim
online-dating vor und das sind nur die
mehr oder weniger sichtbaren einsatzorte
von algorithmen jeder art von
elektronischer kommunikation jeder
einkauf im supermarkt und sogar die
stromversorgung einer stadt nicht
funktioniert heutzutage ohne die hilfe
von algorithmen und innerhalb der
nächsten jahre werden sie sogar noch
viel stärker in unser leben eingreifen
in los angeles ging die einbrüche
letztes jahr fast 30 prozent zurück
grund dafür ist red bull
ein algorithmus der vorhersagen kann mit
welcher wahrscheinlichkeit in welchem
stadtteil verbrechen stattfinden werden
wie eine wettervorhersage bekommt die
polizei dann einen bericht und kann
dementsprechend dort verstärkt
kontrollieren
minority report lässt grüßen viele autos
könnten bereits kleinere aktionen wie
einparken selber übernehmen und es wird
nicht mehr lange dauern bis die
selbstfahrenden autos von google tesla
und großen autoherstellern den markt
übernehmen wenn es soweit ist haben die
algorithmen nicht nur die macht über
leben und tod auf der straße dann sorgen
sie auch dafür dass viele menschen ihre
arbeit verlieren werden mancher taxi lkw
bus und bahnfahrer wird demnächst um
seine stellen bangen müssen
experten warnen bereits vor den
möglichen folgen der algorithmen und das
ist vor allem massenarbeitslosigkeit
denn ganz häufig wird sich auf diese
möglichkeit nicht vorbereitet meine
arbeit ist doch viel zu komplex und von
einem computer gemacht zu werden
auf der website der bbc kann man
herausfinden wie wahrscheinlich es ist
dass dein job in den nächsten 20 jahren
von einem roboter übernommen wird
telefonverkäufer anwaltsgehilfen und
buchhalter stehen alle mit über 95
ganz oben auf der liste mehr glück hat
man wenn der job kontakt mit menschen
und empathie vermögen verlangt und wenn
man neuartige ideen entwickeln muss
psychologen künstler und designer oder
pflegepersonal müssen sich also erst mal
keine allzu großen sorgen machen oder
doch klar
aufgaben die man berechnen und
kalkulieren kann werden bald ersetzt
diese aufgaben sind wie geschaffen für
computer aber was ist mit kreativität
können uns algorithmen auch unterhalten
kann ein computer kunst erschaffen
mein erster instinkt als ich mir diese
frage gestellt habe war mein computer
algorithmen können zwar unglaublich viel
dafür brauchen sie aber ein bestimmtes
set an regeln dass sie genau befolgen
den coach aber es kann nichts neues
entstehen alles was algorithmen können
muss vorher vom programmierer 1 getippt
worden sein
aber wie sich herausstellt braucht man
auch gar nichts neues ein paar einfache
regeln kombiniert mit einem
zufallsgenerator sind häufig schon genug
um uns menschen über den ursprung der
kunst hinwegzutäuschen
nehmen wir als beispiel einmal musik
musik befolgt viele simple regeln
manche akkorde harmonieren miteinander
und manche nicht diese regeln sind so
einfach dass man sie in einem computer
code festhalten kann
dann muss man nur noch etwas abwechslung
anbauen und schon hat man seinen eigenen
computer generierten
was ihr glaubt mir nicht was meint ihr
welchen komponisten wie schon das ganze
video lang zuhört
noch nie hat ein mensch diese melodie
auf einem klavier gespielt
sie wurde generiert und auf knopfdruck
kann man noch tausende weitere neuartige
individueller lieder entstehen lassen
und das in vielen verschiedenen genres
ein möglicher killer der musikindustrie
das sind die animationen von frederik
van houten na ja nicht von ihnen sondern
von seinem computer programm
hunderte zeilen computercode erschaffen
diese bilder bei jedem knopfdruck
entsteht etwas anderes generate of arts
nennt sich diese kunst und findet sich
inzwischen überall im internet nicht
einmal filme sind sicher studenten
verschiedener universitäten entwickelten
dieses jahr ein computerprogramm mit dem
man die mimik eines menschen analysieren
und diese auf einer anderen person in
einem youtube-video anwenden konnte die
studenten demonstrieren dass an
verschiedenen politikern und schneiden
mit deren gesichtern grimassen
das ergebnis ist gleichzeitig
schrecklich lustig und schrecklich
furchteinflößend damit kann man in
zukunft jedem menschen alles in den mund
legen und hat auch noch einen video
beweis
ich hab euch das video mal unten unter
dem like-button verlinkt natürlich ist
auch diese technik nicht perfekt aber
wenn man bedenkt wie gut sie jetzt schon
funktioniert dann bin ich der festen
überzeugung dass wir bald keine
schauspieler mehr brauchen
hey ich meine wofür braucht ihr mich
noch ich könnte in der zukunft einfach
einen text in ein computerprogramm
eingeben und ausgespuckt wird mir ein
video von mir wie ich den text sage aber
da haben wir es doch den text den müssen
weiterhin menschen schreiben oder ein
drehbuch für einen film ist doch
wesentlich komplexer als musiknoten
verschiedene storylines charakter
entwicklungen und plot twists so etwas
kann man doch nicht vorprogrammieren bei
geschichten geht es doch um die
menschlichkeit an sich ich könnte mich
vor freude die ich das erste mal empfand
und ich konnte mich für aufregung
der tag an dem ein computer ein buch
schrieb der computer der sein eigenes
glück priorisierte und aufhörte für die
menschen zu arbeiten
das sind die letzten sätze eines romans
der in die engere auswahl eines
japanischen literaturpreises gekommen
ist die jury lobte die struktur der
geschichte fand die charaktere aber
etwas zu schwach
nachdem die jury bekannt gegeben hatte
welche bücher in die engere auswahl
gekommen sind verkündete ein team
japanischer forscher das unglaubliche
das buch wurde mit hilfe einer
künstlichen intelligenz geschrieben
aber wie so oft liegt der teufel im
detail laut der wissenschaftler hatte
algorithmus nur circa 20 prozent der
arbeit gemacht
diese hoch gelobte struktur des romans
wurde zum beispiel bereits vorher von
einem menschen geschrieben
der algorithmus formulierte dann
einzelne abschnitte selber ohne die
gesamtheit der geschichte verändern zu
können okay
es wird noch lange dauern bis der erste
bestseller von einer maschine
geschrieben wird aber wie ihr seht es
ist möglich die algorithmen werden immer
komplexer und größer und es ist nur eine
frage der zeit bis uns nicht mehr
auffällt dass eigentlich nur simple
regeln und zufall hinter dem stecken was
wir als kunst bezeichnen können computer
kunst erschaffen in einer gewissen art
und weise schon
allerdings würde ich lieber sagen das
programm ihrer kunst erschaffen und ihr
werkzeug ist eben nicht der pinsel oder
die kamera sondern der programmcode
jetzt drängt sich mir nur die frage auf
worin besteht eigentlich die kunst
selber in dem was erzeugt wurde
das was wir als schön bezeichnen würden
oder hier drin
ein coach der zwar allein stehen nicht
wirklich ästhetisch ist dafür aber die
quelle der ursprung der kunst ist für
mich ist das die eigentliche leinwand
des künstlers zum abschluss möchte ich
euch noch testen könnt ihr zwischen
mensch und computer unterscheiden
eines dieser beiden gedichte ist von
einem menschen geschrieben das andere
wurde von einem algorithmus generiert
ich möchte wissen welches der beiden
gedichte wurde von einem menschen
geschrieben
a oder b schreibt mir unten in die
kommentare ich bin schon mega gespannt
was dabei rumkommt
die antwort gibt sonntagabend auf meinen
twitter und facebook seiten
also geht sicher dass ihr erfolg damit
ihr nichts verpasst und jetzt bin ich
auf eure meinung gespannt wo liegt die
kunst im code der das kunstwerk
erschaffen hat oder im kunstwerk selber
schreiben ihr eure gedanken zu dem thema
unten in die kommentare
wenn ich das video gefallen hat dann
könnt ihr mir ein riesen gefallen tun
indem ihr das video hier weiter schickt
und freunden oder der familie zeigt und
ansonsten sage ich vielen dank fürs
schon und bis nächste woche donnerstag